[Music]
meanwhile Michelle Turner is here
because there's another star parent
making a big announcement Jen Jax
absolutely miss Jackson took to Twitter
to say first of all she's resuming her
world tour but Janet also broke her
silence about her divorce Janet herself
for the first time confirms her split
with husband to five years billionaire
Wissam al mana yes I separated from my
husband we are in court and the rest is
in God's hands source close to the
family tells us she will be in court to
flesh out the dissolution of her
marriage touring with baby Issa could be
a possible problem but she's hoping it's
not speaking of touring that's also
something we learned from Janet's new
posting it's back on I'm so excited you
guys so excited completely put on hold
when she announced her plans to start a
family the tour now called state of the
world will open in Lafayette Louisiana I
cannot wait to see you on stage
September 7
[Music]
Janet also admitted to gaining some baby
weight which her brother Randy chimed in
on I have put on quite a few since I had
the baby because can you please be quiet
Randy but our source tells us that Janet
will begin rigorously dieting she wants
to look her best for herself and for her
fans thank you so much oh no no no thank
you
Shannon for getting back on stage and
also for giving me something to do on
October 8th when she comes to Lhasa
mm-hmm yeah girl I will be there you
will I will be there Janet
[Music]
you